welcome back to las vegas now tomorrow
is national dance day and a great excuse
to twerk like nobody's watching you know
so sanjay jackson up to working tone is
here to get the party started a little
early which we are not mad about welcome
ladies hi hi introduce us to your lovely
assistant this is kim also known as ken
from the bay him from the bay and chante
i like that i like that so first before
we get into you know
moving yes let's talk
does what does dance mean to you because
it's national dance day and it's more
than just you know moving your body
that's a message too dan's for me it
truly is is the expression of your soul
at the end of the day um i was diagnosed
with adhd as a child and one of the
suggestions that doctor gave my mother
was put her into dance classes and
little did we know it was going to be
absolutely my passion and what i would
fall in love with wow and from that
fashion comes twerk and tone dance
fitness so introduce us to that okay so
twerk and tone dance fits this is going
to be your hit performance based uh
dance fitness program so i mean not
intense but i mean we can get there
we've got a little bit energy we can get
there and it's really for those that
thrive in an environment that is like in
a dance environment so cheerleaders
dancers performers here on the strips
and also moms we really want to speak to
our mothers for our moms to come out and
give some time back to yourself i'm a
mom of three turn 39 in july wow okay go
go go go now um what would you say
because i know you mentioned athletes
but moms i think there's a lot of them
watching right now what do you what kind
of feedback do you get from them
moms it's it's my this is my time this
is my moment so what i share in my
classes is that from the moment you step
in that door whatever title is attached
to that mom sister cousin on whatever
that looks like release that title and
just become completely you because this
is your time i love that and there are
online classes as well if you can't make
it into youtube videos the website yes i
invite you by shantae.com join us online
join us online but join us right now
because i know you guys are going to
dance a little bit a little bit
right now what are we doing what are we
doing we are going to dance in vegas to
vegas it's going to be a cute little
tick tock we've already posted it in the
mood make sure you tag us and we're
going to get it
all right i'll step outside
you ain't nothing
[Music]
hey
and that's it
wait let me do a little sexy part i can
do that
roll roll
roll
oh
i love it i love it again tell everybody
how they can get in touch with you head
over to my website
ianbodybyshante.com and you'll find all
the information twerk and tone everybody
ladies and gentlemen